well welcome welcome to your mom's house
with Tom Segura Christina the ship's
to yourselves okay let me see if he
answered please please answer I want to
hear those lips hello yes hey Dad hey
buddy how you doing hey um you got a
second for me I had so much fun reading
jokes to you the other day I got some
new one submitted can I read them to you
oh sure love joke okay uh these are just
women jokes okay ah every strata lab
already okay how do you blind a woman I
give up
you put a windshield in front of her oh
my god okay let's see why do women have
periods I've been kind of figure that
out for a long time okay well the answer
is because they deserve them what do you
call a woman without an asshole you know
I'm trying to think I can't even think
of anything I'm not you know you know
you don't have to think of anything
because these are just setup punchline
jokes okay okay I don't know I don't
know okay so I'll read it again what do
you call a woman without an asshole I
have no idea single how do you know
Polish girls on her period how do you
know a Polish girl is on her period I
don't know she's only wearing one sock
she's only wearing one side oh that's
brutal oh that's brutal
I propose people up that's brutal
what's another meaning for for a woman
like I don't know another
description for the word woman I am the
idea finger puppet okay remember that
one before
yeah maybe just the wife jokes um so
really really just mean uh how do you
know your girlfriend is getting fat I
don't know she fits into your wife's
clothes
oh that's British oh I love that one
process oh that's a good one Tommy uh
what's the difference between a knife
and a woman arguing I don't know a knife
has a point
ooh that's brutal
that's brutal Wow
what do women and come what do women and
condoms have in common
ah I can't take you an answer if they're
not on your dick they're in your wallet
well that's a great one Oh Mike
that is a great one let's do blonde can
we do what takes up 12 parking spaces ah
to watch know what why do you do this
why do you deliver jokes okay gonna get
ready yet do it again now go to another
hold on now I want to get back to the
parking lot okay like market I wanna
okay so Tommy about the park you buy
joke every time now I go to park a lot
I'll see a blonde I'll think of it okay
tell me the parking light okay what
takes up 12 parking spaces I don't know
six females
and watch this is actually what's what's
five miles long and has an IQ of 40 I
have no idea a blonde parade let me see
I got a couple more for you okay okay uh
why did the blonde eat a dictionary I
give up because you wanted to be smart
oh this is good
what that buddy
I just heard sounds like you're doing
something yeah thank holy God so there
yes I'm supposed to wash my hands just
want people to think I really do that
dad done yes right yep wash my ass buddy
good for you it says we probably watched
one but how how did the blonde break her
leg raking leaves I give up
she fell out of the tree oh my god yeah
these are good I'm glad good bunny where
are you writing are you home yeah okay
all right look I love you I love you
I'll give you a call later fuck you
buddy love you bye bye Henry